[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
going out for a little morning walk
good morning
breakfast bagels
[Music]
[Music]
cheers cheers thank you for breakfast
welcome
so freaking good
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
what do you think should i bring the van
out here
so we are out exploring today and um
we're just
rumbling down some dirt roads they're
actually pretty sandy so
nate just ran ahead to make sure it
wasn't too deep
looks uh are we good
yeah we're good all right we're gonna
keep going
[Music]
okay so we are out exploring and i am
stoked to be shooting on the lumix g100
honestly i have been trying to work out
what kind of
video camera setup i should be using for
everyday vlogging
um i'm new to youtube and i'm a
photographer so
it's kind of a whole new thing for me to
figure out lately
i've just been shooting with my iphone
and yeah like that gets the job done
but if i want to shoot for instagram
stories or
set up a time lapse or just be on my
phone
it means that i can't vlog very easily
the g100 is designed as a vlogging
camera
so it's perfect for what i do and yeah
there's a couple reasons why i love it
this camera is lightweight and compact
and
i live in a van so that's a big deal i'm
always trying to minimize my
gear and also maximize my storage space
it also has
face tracking which is great if you're
moving around a lot
there's also wind reduction which is a
setting that's super helpful if you're
say outside or on a mountain top you can
turn that on and it has this
flip out screen the handle turns into a
tripod which is super convenient
so if i want i can just set it up
like that the lenses are interchangeable
there is
a hot shoe for a microphone attachment i
am currently recording
without any stabilization and i am just
walking along
at a medium pace here i am walking again
surprise but this is with standard
stabilization turned on here is high
stabilization so
as you can see it crops in a little bit
but it's definitely
nice and smooth so you have a couple
different options depending on what
you're trying to film
i don't have a ton of experience with
audio
especially like i'm still learning how
to capture it and how to edit it
but this camera takes a lot of the
guesswork out of the process
it has advanced ozo tracking
so it will follow me along with the face
detection
and follow the sound of my voice those
are just a few of the things that i love
about the camera so far
and yeah like i said i'm working with
panasonic on this project i'm super
stoked about it
and as a thanks there might be something
in it for you guys
just stick around to the end of the
video to find out more
we are heading back to the truck and
it's getting kind of cold out
and yeah we have like another hour
before sunset
we're gonna head back and make some
dinner all right nathaniel
yes
yes
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we just uh put out the campfire and now
we're inside the van it got kind of cold
outside so
we are firing up the stove and nathaniel
is cooking dinner
and according to him we're having fungus
tacos that's right fungus tacos yeah it
sounds delicious it's like a protein
what is a protein something microprotein
microprotein made of fungi so
but we're having tacos which is one of
my favorites
oh that's good i'm just creating a
little bed of
kale here bam okay now we're gonna put
the meat on here
fifty shades of green
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you